LIke you said,
it's sort of an old school way doing it.
They were the first methods being used
in what's called pattern recognition.
Pattern recognition's entire field or
discipline that looked at making
these kinds of decisions.
And one of the reasons was it was
very easy to model this analytically.
Because you'd use things like Gaussians,
or whatever.
Or mixtures of Gaussians, and you could
do this with modest amounts of data
in a smallish moderate
number of dimensions, and
because a lot of this was done
before we had serious computers, or
before we had serious data.
This was really important.
But sort of in the modern world, or
not even the modern world anymore, but
the world 20 years ago, which I like to
think of as being modern, because back
then I was in my 30s, and I'm hoping
that I'm not like, really that old.
But now I'm like,
man I'm old, okay fine.
But in the modern world there are some
liabilities of the generative method.
First of all, these days, many of our
signals are high-dimensional, right.
So we get some description of a signal,
whether it's stock market data or
whatever it is.
I might have a feature space that's
tens of thousands of dimensions,
or at least many hundreds of dimensions.
It's a very high-dimensional vector.
And if you actually want to represent
the density, in that high-dimensional
space I, I wrote here that
it's called sort of data hard.
And what I mean by that is
the thing becomes exponential in
the number of features that you have.
So you have to have sort of massive,
massive, massive amounts of data.
And even more mass, when, you know,
we tend to think sort of Google
styles data being is massive.
No.
You know, when you've got tens of
thousands of dimensions, it, it's,
the amount of data you need to densely
sample that is, is exponential,
and we just don't have it.
But, there's even a bigger liability,
okay?
The bigger liability is that
we don't actually care about
modelling the coal class.
Right?
If I've got sort of skin things and
not skin things.
Imagine a whole bunch of colored pixels
that have nothing to do with skin,
I don't have to model that as not skin.
We only care about making
the right decisions.
So we should be modelling
the boundaries, the hard cases.
The cases where I'm not really sure.
And when you do a general model
of a category or of a class,
you're worried about the vast majority
of them, so the skin pixels, not this,
just this boundary that's
next to the non-skin ones.
And I'm not even totally sure
what it means to model non-class,
non-skin pixels, because that's
everything from you know, the pixels on
colored shirts, to the pixels on grass,
to the pixels on tree bark.
Yeah, it's kind of a weird, not,
non skin's not really a great class.
What I care about is, find me the pixels
that may be labeled as skin, or
maybe not.
And finally,
I'm going to give you a feature vector,
a bunch of features that
describe an instance.
And we might not have any idea,
a priori,
which features actually are good for
discriminating between the classes.
So part of our building a classifier
is essentially doing feature selection,
right?
We have to figure out what
parts of the features, or
what parts of the signal,
are the sort of informative ones.
And, so, for
training a classifier, our general model
has no way of talking about doing that.
But the methods we're
about to talk about,
which are called discriminative methods,
inherently do that.